ever marry from a weak position never
commit from a weak position what I mean
from a weak position you know when you
see red flags and you're like everybody
knows that you see the red flags and you
choose to ignore them why because that's
the only option you have and like I tell
guys in our company when they join
they're in the early 20s I'm like don't
like don't commit to the first girl you
freaking kiss man because you're like
there's things you're not going to see
like go and run the hose just straight
up I go go through the 304s run it run
it run it run it so that sorry man
that's a very different I expect you to
have more of a trap no yeah